make way for his majesty chow yun-fat
this year's nominees for best
achievement in some effects editing
skillfully handle thousands of punches
kicks guns and spaceships yet anomalies
grand clients and Richard Ames for fight
huh
Payne a Davis for the matrix
then bird and Tom Belton for Star Wars
Episode one The Phantom Menace
I know Oscar goes to Danny Davis for the
matrix
Oscar nomination for gain a
Wow
so this is where the rabbit hole goes uh
I want to thank Larry and Andy Wachowski
and Joel silver Zach Steinberg and
everybody at Warner Brothers for
trusting me with such a terrific movie
it was a blast from start to finish I
want to thank our mixers John Greg and
Dave and congratulations I want to thank
my terrific crew led by Julie ever shade
Eric Lindemann and John Rush I think my
mother and father my wife Francine my
sons Jeremy and Ryan for being there for
me when I came back from being in the
matrix this is a great honor thank you
everyone in the Academy thank you
you know just thinking between on Javita
Chang fat and salma hayek John Rocker
must be going nuts
please welcome someone else was going to
upset him or shoes biggest export since
the Von Trapp family
Arnold Schwarzenegger
good evening I'm here today to present
your word for outstanding visual effects
this is really exciting for me because
while you may not know how much
inspiration imagination and plain hard
work goes into creating this magic I
know because I have been a visual effect
half of my career I have spent hanging
from a helicopter like in True Lies or
riding a motorcycle through fire like in
the Terminator or having a repairman go
inside my head I can totally recall also
now I know what it is like to be in a
receiving end of all that crazy demented
talent of this craftsman but tonight I'm
going to be on the other end I'm going
to be in the giving end that this year's
nominees took us on a trip so the matrix
of time and the trip to the galaxy far
far away and on a trip through Central
Park with a little mouse named Stuart
here are the nominees for outstanding
visual effects for the matrix chunk ADA
Yannick sirs Steve Kot Lee and John Tom
for Star Wars Episode one The Phantom
Menace
John nor Dennis Muren Scott Squires and
Rob Coleman for Stuart Little John
Dykstra sharone
Jen Henry if Anderson the third and Eric
alert and the Oscar goes to John Gator
Yannick Searles
Spieth portly enchant um for the matrix
data Yanik sir
young tongue
future eyes filmmaking Indian Larry
wachowski this is their vision on the
screen these guys made my decade they
gave my career a path and I am a most
thankful and they are great friends of
all of ours
they're very by the heart
they're making their films I'd like to
dedicate this to my son Skylar this is
inspiration
like to thank my wife rose for standing
by me through all of this like to thank
the executive producers Barry Osborne
Andrew Mason ultra producer Joel Silver
I'd like to thank Lorenzo de Bonaventure
of Warner Brothers for standing behind a
very risky picture and really making
this film what the filmmakers wanted it
to be I want to point out that there are
some great visual effects companies that
did this picture MV effects Rob Bobo
thank you very much for putting all of
your efforts behind innovation behind
the spirit of doing visual effects in
service to a story I'd like to thank
Animal Logic and D film for quality work
and a great experience and most of all
the artists what is the matrix com go
there
oscar-winning composer Burt Bacharach
72nd
Awards four times
you